[MUSIC PLAYING]
Fokus is a very
simple tool for people
who want to know
everything about analytics.
We suck up the information
and present, very beautifully,
on the simple dashboard.
And this is something
very cool for people
who want to have the
electronic pulse.
The first time I
approached the person
that I was thinking
about as an investor,
he told me that he didn't
see me as an entrepreneur,
as a CEO of this
company, because I
have lots of things to do.
I have my own startup.
I have my two
other things to do.
I'm very active on social media.
I do Aula Polska.
I'm a blogger.
I'm a person.
I'm a mentor.
So there's lots of things.
You have to be well known
because of one thing.
And then, it struck me
that I have to focus.
That's also the
name of the company.
So let's focus on something-- on
one thing-- and be good at it.
And everything will follow.
For many startups,
it's like you don't
know if your product is ready.
You know that your product is
ready because of the pipeline
of your clients.
But for you-- for
the entrepreneur,
as a person, who
created the startup--
it's like a
never-ending process.
You see your features
and you're thinking
about the next two, three steps.